[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein ließ
welt heute zeige ich euch wie ich meinen
frühjahrsputz mache ich hatte euch auf
instagram gefragt ob ihr das sehen wollt
wie ich alles organisiere und mache und
dazu habt ihr glaube ich zu 95 prozent
zucker mit ja abgestimmt
frühjahrsputz bedeutet für mich nicht
dass ich bis dahin alles liegenlassen
und verdreckten lasse frühjahrsputz
bedeutet für mich dass ich das haus was
sowieso schon aufgeräumt und sauber ist
im prinzip auf vordermann bringen und so
von grund auf putze das heißt alles was
ich im alltag eben nicht mache wie zum
beispiel die fliesen an der wand oder
dass man eben alles mal rein macht alles
im dampfreiniger sau gemacht das sind so
dinge die ich beim frühjahrsputz mache
also wirklich einmal von grund auf aber
bis dahin solltet ihr schon vieles
vorbereitet du putzt gleich den boden
aber ich zeige dir gleich wie bis dahin
solltet ihr natürlich alles schon
vorbereiten das heißt ich nehme dann
immer jeden tag einen raum vor den ich
aus liste und auf räume und dann kann
ich an dem tag wo ich eben den
frühjahrsputz machen möchte wirklich
alles auch komplett sauber machen
ihr könnt euch das ganze auch gut
aufteilen auf zwei tage vor allem wenn
ihr ein zweigeschossiges haus hat wenn
eine wohnung habe ist es vielleicht
einfacher je nachdem wie viele zimmer
ihr habt und wie voll alles steht und
wie gesagt lasst bis dahin nicht alles
vertreten
ich kann gerne auch mal so ein putz
routine video machen dann seht ihr wie
wir im haushalt alles jeden tag sauber
halten also wir schon jeden tag bis bad
wir machen jeden tag die küche so bot
die toiletten und dann habt ihr es auch
später wirklich viel einfacher los gehts
ich starte jetzt oben bei unserem
obergeschoss am besten immer von oben
nach unten arbeiten und wenn ihr eine
wohnung habe dann einfach von hinten
nach vorne arbeiten und wir gehen jetzt
nach oben packen unsere sachen und dann
geht's los
[Musik]
was ich zu hause habe ist ein putzeimer
und zwar hier ein körbchen wo ich
wirklich alles drin habe dass ich jetzt
für den frühjahrsputz oder auch für den
alltäglichen putz brauche ich habe das
ganze hier auch so ein rollcontainer
gestellt denn dann müsste es nicht
mittragen sondern können einfach mit
euch herzlich und es hat so ist
natürlich auch den vorteil ich kann es
mit teddy oder eben ohne benutzen und
den korb einfach mitnehmen
ich hab hier zu finden eine küchenrolle
ich benutze gummihandschuhe denn egal
mit welchen reinigern ihre putzt ihr
solltet ihr mal gummihandschuhe tragen
oder ihre hände zu schützen
dann habe ich hier noch einmal ein
fahrrad ich habe hier einen normalen
schwamm unserem schmutz radierer den
brauche ich auch immer wieder denn
obwohl es verboten ist malen die kinder
gerne doch mal was an die wand oder ich
habe einen fleck da nicht raus geht dann
klickt hier auch ein cerankochfeld
schaber denn es kann auch mal sein dass
ich irgendwo an der glatten stelle am
glas zum beispiel was habe was ich dann
wirklich super einfach weg kratzen kann
zettel und stift wenn wir was auffällt
ist aber nicht vergessen möchte oder ihr
benutzt einfach die notizfunktion auch
warum handy geht natürlich auch ein
staubwedel alles weg einiger den mache
ich gerne selber den habe ich dann hier
einfach in der sprühflasche drin für
mich habe ich noch taschentücher und
bonbons oder kaugummis putztücher und
hier unten habe ich auch noch putztücher
im vorrat
ich habe hier auf dem rollwagen auch
noch platz für dinge die gleich anfallen
werden
ich habe hier noch ein eimer mit wasser
und ganz ganz wichtig wo habe ich jetzt
hin
hier holten die solltet ihr auch immer
dabei haben denn man findet unterwegs
immer etwas was in den müll gehört und
so kann ich jetzt schon mal eine
mülltüte bereit machen und zeigt euch
was sich jetzt beim frühjahrsputz auch
als erstes noch direkt mache gern bei
uns im ganzen haus keine gardinen daher
muss jetzt keine gardinen abhängen und
waschen
das war immer so das erste was er über
meiner mama gemacht haben was ja was
machen wertet das könnt ihr auch zuerst
machen schon mal alle betten abziehen
dann kann man nämlich die bettwäsche
waschen und eben auch hier innen drin
die bettdecke waschen und dann habt ihr
das auch wieder alles schön sauber und
du kannst jetzt schon mal dein zimmer
solange aufräumen okay
[Musik]
von mir habt ihr auch in der bettwäsche
bei den waschraum die küche und das
badezimmer mache ich zum schluss denn
man muss ja auch immer wieder am sparte
zimmer gehen das einzige badezimmer was
ich gleich machen kann ist dass von den
kindern aber ich werde jetzt hier
einfach zu machen und geht es hier von
raum zu raum
ich sage es mal bei ella an denn die
brauchen ein bisschen motivation
hella wir machen sauber
[Musik]
und ich werde es einfach so die
restlichen dinge aufräumen staubwischen
saubermachen alles immer in einem zug
okay dann habt ihr nicht so viel arbeit
ich habe jetzt hier ein allzweckreiniger
meint kann jetzt hier schön alles sauber
machen
ich mache den alltag reiniger immer
selber gerade bei spielsachen und
kinderzimmern kommt ist auch wichtig
dass man nicht so viel chemie benutzt
sondern wirklich eine natürliche
reiniger
die primären schuhe trage immer so und
schlagt hier und den bund um falls ihr
nämlich nach seiner hände habt und hoch
geht läuft euch nicht alles in den
ellbogen rein sondern alles hier rein
[Musik]
pflanzen haben sie übrigens auch ganz
gerne wenn sie sauber gemacht werden
entweder stofftier sie ganz vorsichtig
ab oder er gibt sie in die dusche und
macht so ein bisschen wasser drüber das
haben sie auch gern so mache ich das
wenn es auch schön gebessert und später
kommen sie dann sauber wieder in die
zimmer zurück
[Musik]
wenn ich dann so dinge finde wie zum
beispiel der becher hier
der gehört eigentlich ins bad dann kommt
es hier auch einen rollcontainer dann
muss ich nämlich jetzt nicht die ganze
zeit hin und herlaufen und kann wirklich
zeit sparen
alles im rollcontainer lagern und dann
von zimmer zu zimmer alles abarbeiten
weg räumen wbl
zum frühjahrsputz gehört auch für coach
dass wir uns von dingen trennen
ich bin erst mal deine bilder
aussortieren also ruhig auch mal
wegschmeißen mit keine schönen bilder
ich hab hier oben so ein
erinnerungskiste wo einfach schöne dinge
von den kindern drin sind aber ich muss
zugeben da kann ich alles aufgeben das
schöne einhorn legen wieder zurück aber
zu mit der lehre briefumschlag der horst
da kommt hier rein
[Musik]
das kannst du noch anmalen und das auch
und weil so regalen immer von oben nach
unten arbeiten damit ihr einfach den
schmutz von oben nach unten könnt und
ich mache jetzt erstmal alle oberflächen
auch die anderen räume das erste zimmer
hier ist jetzt schon mal fertig und dann
geht es gleich weiter mit den fenstern
[Musik]
für die leisten habe ich denn hier noch
ein staub magnet denn da clubs meist
wenn man dann nach drüber wischt
[Musik]
es gibt es erstmal eine kaffeepause ganz
kurz ich hab jetzt im ganzen
obergeschoss alle oberflächen gemacht
alles aufgeräumt
das sind doch erst recht die meiste zeit
borat saugt gerade noch und er kriegt
auch zwischen kaffee und dann geht es
hier unten weiter und danach gehe ich
direkt schon an die fenster und
schreiben kann fensterputzen
jetzt geht's ans fenster putzen und wir
haben ziemlich viele fensterscheiben
glastüren hier im haus deswegen zeige
ich euch wie wir das jetzt machen und
zwar haben wir uns was geholt zum einen
einen fenster sauger dann nehme ich
jetzt den großen aufsatz
ich hatte aber auch noch einen kleinen
aufsatz für kleine spiegel zum beispiel
also damit hätte ich jetzt auch oben er
laut spiegel machen können und entweder
könnte dann damit mit einer sprühflasche
noch arbeiten und das fenster sozusagen
einfach nachmachen und eben sauberen und
damit abziehen oder ihr nehmt einfach so
ein akku wizard da ist für uns auch
praktischer weil sie einfach wirklich
extrem viele fenster haben und wir
ansonsten glaube ich nie fertig werden
wirken also hier einmal das hier und
jetzt nehmen wir noch einen reiniger
ich habe ich die pats die sich auch
bereits gewaschen
wenn ihr solche gehabt egal für welche
anwendung auch immer auch boden
wischtücher die sollten immer vor dem
ersten gebrauch gewaschen werden nun
immer ohne weichspüler waschen also
wirklich nur waschmittel und es reicht
und fertig ich habe alles immerhin der
box hier sind noch die kabel für die
akkus zum aufladen wenn das ganze ist
aktiv betrieben das ist ganz praktisch
nichts nach der anwendung einfach wieder
aufladen steht sogar drauf wie lange ich
noch akkulaufzeit habe also echt
praktisch hier wird es hier auch den
fensterreiniger der dazu gehört denn es
kommt auch immer darauf an welche
reiniger waren benutzt beim
fensterputzen ganze zeit lang auch
einfach mit essig gemacht oder geschirr
einiger geschirrspüler
aber es kann passieren dass es streife
ich wird und wenn ihr dann das erste mal
einen richtigen fensterreiniger benutzt
der hat zum beispiel auch eine
beschichtung das einfach regenwasser zum
beispiel eben schön abperlt dann wenn
die fenster auch nie wieder
schnell schmutzig und dann muss man
wirklich so dass alte die ganzen alten
reiniger erstmal weg waschen und dann
wird es eben richtig
also ich mach das jetzt hier rein
braucht man auch nur ganz wenig 20
milliliter und dann fühle ich den rest
mit wasser auf wir haben zwar eine bwt
anlage also eine filteranlage aber ich
nehme es trotzdem destilliertes wasser
denn 30 0 kalk drin
das hole ich mal eben kurz kommt es hier
rein und stadt destilliertem wasser
könnt ihr auch regenwasser verwenden
werden auch externe und sammeln
regenwasser zum einen kostenlos und zum
anderen von natur aus schon bald frei
das war kommt wir putzen die fenster
dann mache ich jetzt an und gefriert das
heißt es gleich nicht stoppen sondern
lass einfach das gerät arbeiten muss ich
das befeuchten also bis zum wasser damit
ist hoch mit wasser benetzt wird und
dann fange ich erst mal innen haben mit
allen glasflächen und geht dann an die
schmutzigen fenster
[Musik]
und solange es bräuchte es dann wenn
sauger abziehen
[Musik]
so machts fensterputzen auch wieder spaß
und vor allem tropft halt einfach nix es
seht schon der boden bleibt schön sauber
und ich komme wirklich bis ganz nach
unten obwohl das glas fast bis nach
unten geht zu boden
[Musik]
das mutterschiff logisches krieg start
weg ohne zu schreiben also die
rückstände von insekten gehen damit auch
gut mit bevor das sagen
[Musik]
hier haben geländer muss ich wirklich
jeden tag ran denn wir haben leider ein
glas geländer würde ich übrigens nicht
mehr empfehlen sieht zwar schön aus aber
wenn man kinder hat das ist wirklich
anfällig jetzt mache ich erstmal den
handlauf und dann die scheibe
[Musik]
wollt ihr für euch wir hatten noch gar
nicht alle räume gesagt glaube ich
[Musik]
jetzt sind die großen fenster an der
reihe und die klar von außen und innen
die rahmen muss ich natürlich auch
putzen und was fast noch wichtiger ist
die scheiben sind immer schmutzig klar
wegen den kindern auch die rennen dann
immer dagegen
aber was ich auch ganz wichtig sind hier
unten das werde ich jetzt erstmal alles
frei saugen
ich habe zum beispiel auch teilweise
blätter und laub drin weil wir jetzt im
winter auch nicht so oft offen hatten
wir haben auch eine belüftungsanlage das
heißt im winter wird bei uns fast nie
das fenster geöffnet
und deswegen ist ja alles schmutzig
jetzt wird hier alles weg gesagt und
dann mache ich hier unten erst mal alle
foul
[Musik]
bei allen geräten auch beim bügeleisen
immer am besten destilliertes wasser
nehmen es hat keine kalkbildung und
jetzt nehme ich den dampfreiniger um
alle porentief zu reinigen
ich erkläre euch jetzt mal den
reinigungs kreis ich habs grad ne yos
erklärt aber ich erkläre es euch auch
also ihr müsst euch das putzen wir einen
kreis vorstellen und entweder nehmen wir
zum beispiel ich sage jetzt mal
backblech ok hatten ein gebranntes
backblech entweder nimmt jetzt einfach
nur wasser weicht das backblech damit
ein und muss dann einfach auf die zeit
gehen das heißt ihr habt den faktor zeit
und müsste es hier 24 stück eindecken
lassen vermisst sich der schmutz vom
blech eben ablöst dann gibt's noch den
faktor mechanik also schrubben das heißt
wenn ihr wasser benutzt und dann noch
schrubbt dann wird natürlich die der
zeitfaktor kleiner und die mechanik
kommt dazu also heißt warten einwirken
lassen und dann ab schrubben
dann gibt's noch den faktor chemie das
heißt reinigungsmittel
wenn ihr das nämlich benutzt gibt es
einfach reiniger die sind etwas
schwächer
da müsste es ein wecken lassen etwas
schrubben also ihr habt dann diese drei
faktoren zeit chemie und eben mechanik
und dann geht es natürlich auch reiniger
die so stark sind dass der faktor zeit
oder mechanik wegfällt dh jetzt so viel
chemie mit drin dass sie nicht mehr
stoppen müsste und nicht einwickeln
lassen müsst das ist der faktor chemie
gewesen und dann gibt es noch den faktor
hitze also temperatur
wenn wir zum beispiel dinge mit heißem
wasser oder dampf reinigt dann fällt auf
die chemie weg wenn der dampfdruck
reiniger benutzt oder das feld der
faktor zeit weg und so könnt ihr euch
diesen kreis vorstellen mit den vier
faktoren also zeit mechanik reiniger
beziehungsweise chemie und eben hitze
jetzt könnt ihr hier diese fensterrahmen
zum beispiel habe ich ja starke
verschmutzungen weil einfach der ganze
winter hier den ganzen schmutz an
gespült hat entweder mit einem starken
reiniger reinigen und ein bisschen
shoppen das ganze mit wasser einwirken
lassen und später abwaschen oder indem
zum beispiel hochdruckreinigers und
dampfdruck reiniger verwendet also
heißen dampf und dafür brauchte wirklich
gar kein reinigungsmittel und so mache
ich das jetzt und dampf hat eben auch
den vorteil dass es 99 9
trainer abtötet und gerade beim
frühjahrsputz muss ich sagen benutze ich
super gerne ich benutze auch in der
küche im badezimmer für die böden und so
wird alles rein und alles sauber ohne
chemie und das mache ich jetzt
ich benutze ziel vorne ich habe hier
schon wasser eingefüllt da habe ich
natürlich wieder destilliertes wasser
ihr könnt aber auch leitungswasser
nehmen müssten nur dann irgendwann das
gerät natürlich entkalken je nachdem wo
er lebt und wie viel kalkül wasser
hatten also ich mach das jetzt hier mit
sauber und arbeite hier zum einen mit
der mechanik ich habe also hier diese
bürste und eben mit dem heißen dampf am
anfang kommt jetzt hier erst mal wasser
nur aus weil das rohr natürlich noch
ganz kalt ist und der heiße dampf
kondensiert ganz normal und dann benutze
ich diese bürste ich habe aber auch noch
andere aufsätze ich gucke jetzt einfach
mal an die kleinen stellen komme ich mit
der bürste nicht ran aber dafür mit dem
druck also mit der kleinen düse
aufgewärmt ist muss man das rohr kurz
heiß werden
[Musik]
dann einfach mit einem tuch nachwischen
schon ist es sauber
[Musik]
pd
fr
[Musik]
jetzt sind die fenster von außen dran
und weil der außen ziemlich stark
verschmutzt sind gehe ich erstmal mit
dampfreiniger dran und dann mit meinem
fensterreiniger morath so lange drinnen
fertig weil die oberflächen sind gemacht
und jetzt habe ich nur noch die fenster
und dann können erwischen
man sieht richtig wie es wasser abperlt
weil ich einfach immer mit einem
reiniger drüber geht zitiert
[Musik]
der außenputz sich jetzt noch mit meinem
allzweckreiniger die ganzen rahmen also
1000 hat man echtem omega viel dreck hat
sich alles schöne hammer und da hinten
kam ich jetzt auch an die scheibe nicht
ran
in einem fliegengitter was mache ich
dann einfach so und die ecke da komme
ich mit der hand nicht dran da muss ich
mit dampfreiniger mit der düse dran
da wird hier der dreck ausgepustet
[Musik]
als ein suchen sich echt sagen man putzt
hier mit deutlich weniger wasser wenn
ich mir vorstelle ich meiner mama früher
auch immer schon die fenster und alles
geputzt hat man immer so einen putzeimer
gehabt und den haben wir bestimmt fünf
sechs mal lernen müssen und hier habe
ich jetzt gerade mal zum zweiten mal den
tank aufgefüllt als ich habe insgesamt
erst mal 400 bis 500 milliliter wasser
verbraucht auch ganz wenig
fensterreiniger nur schon ziemlich
effizient und mit echten wenigen
kleineren wasserverbrauch und topstar
aufnehmen wenn ihr dann alle fenster
geputzt habt geht's an die möbel pflege
werden hier ein ledersofa und das sollte
man natürlich auch reinigen aber auch
bewegen leder ist einfach nach haut das
heißt die haut darf nicht porös werden
sie soll nicht brüchig werden und nicht
reißen daher wirklich nur mit ph haut
neutralen reinigern reinigen ich habe
jetzt noch was von unserem sofa da also
das wird direkt mitgeliefert wenn ihr
sowas aber nicht habt nehmt ihr einfach
ein waschmittel was für die haut
geeignet ist also ich habe zum beispiel
für die kinder und für mich auch immer
mehr haut neutrales hat waschmittel
damit mache ich auf das gesicht zaubern
damit könnt ihr sauber machen und danach
wird es noch gepflegt als ihr beziehungs
schwämmchen und gäbe es hier drauf schön
sauber machen
wichtig ist hier ein weichen schwamm zu
nehmen und dann eher mit kreisenden
bewegungen hier den schmutz zu entfernen
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen trotz einwirken geht
es hier nicht weg ich probier sind einem
dampfreiniger also faktor chemie hat
jetzt nicht geholfen
jetzt muss doch die temperatur dran aber
ich zeige euch dann ein trick wie es
ganz ganz vorsichtig machen könnt denn
hier dürfte jetzt nicht volle pulle mit
dem heißen strahl dran so man muss etwas
vorsichtiger arbeiten und zwar setzt
sich jetzt die düse seitlich an also
nicht frontal sondern seitlich und
fangen mit dem tuch dann den schmuck
sozusagen auf vorsichtig sein dampfes
deswegen auch handschuhe
[Musik]
das buch stützt den ganzen schmutz
hektisch so cool
trotz nach und nach der reinigung ist es
wie bei der gesichts- und hautpflege
eben auch da muss natürlich noch mal
feuchtigkeit zurück an die haut also
aufs leder
entweder nimmt jetzt eine lederpflege
oder einfach ganz günstig eine hautcreme
die auch selbst benutzt am besten ohne
parfum ohne weitere konservierungsstoffe
wirklich nur eine rückfettende hautcreme
und damit könnt ihr jetzt eure polster
schimpf lege ich habe vorher das tuch so
ein bisschen befeuchtet drei platziert
damit ein und dann kann es optimal
einziehen
[Musik]
noch einfacher geht s eincremen übrigens
wenn ihr einfach baumwollhandschuhe
nimmt die creme dazwischen
so spart ihr euch wirklich das teure
leder mittel und dann passieren rollt
sich auch kein tuch unter euren händen
zusammen
[Musik]
ich hab da gesehen so pflege ist die
gesichtspflege erstmal schön gründlich
reinigen mit einem ph haut neutrale
waschmittel als mit einer variation und
dann pflegen mit einer schönen
rückfettenden creme mit ganz einfachen
mitteln ganz einfach ein hausschuh
erhard haus anschauen
die kommen jetzt in die wäsche die kann
ich wieder verwenden das sind nämlich
baumwollhandschuhe und meine hände sind
auch gleichzeitig geprägt so lederpflege
habe ich gemacht die betten sind
abgezogen ich habe es auch schon wieder
bezogen fenster zum geburtstag flächen
sind geputzt
jetzt bleibt eigentlich nur noch der
fußboden küche und bad mache ich morgen
erst das wird mir sonst zu viel heute
fußboden pflege und dann bin ich erst
mal fertig für heute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mache ich schon mal die reiniger also
schön hier vom quadrat zum quadrat
und du kannst einfach ins wasser gleich
serviert einfach nachfüllen ohne
auszumachen hat eine kurze aufheizzeit
[Musik]
ok warte man dann können wir gerade
ausmachen
genau und dann einfach hier unten
drauftreten abziehen und fertig okay ich
räume ist alles gut
danke jetzt haben wir den boden richtig
schön gereinigt und ich muss sagen mit
dem dampfreiniger das machen wir
wirklich jede woche weil es einfach
super einfach geht ich finde sogar
einfacher als wischwasser und
reinigungsmittel herzustellen
denn erfüllt im prinzip nur wasser auf
und samira kannte subakute murat ganz
gut und ich weiß einfach dass alles
schön rein und sauber ist jetzt mache
ich habe hier noch eine bodenpflege und
die nehmen wir einfach so zum täglichen
gebrauch also tägliche pflege und zum
saubermachen zum wischen wir haben bei
uns oben holzböden also parkett hier
unten haben wir sichtbeton estrich und
natürlich auch diese zement mosaik
platten und die müssen eben auch
gepflegt werden
da braucht jetzt aber keine teuren
reinigungsmittel und auch nicht den
ganzen schrank voll stellen mit
holzboden reiniger mit weniger
sichtbeton reiniger sondern ihr braucht
im prinzip einfach nur schmierseife
schmierseife ist so das günstigste was
man bekommen kann
die wird auf basis von natürlichen
seifen hergestellt und da kostet ein
liter 95 cent und die gibt es wirklich
in jedem supermarkt ich nehme jetzt hier
einfach einen putzeimer da hab ich schon
fünf liter wasser drin
kommt jetzt hier ein käpsele voll
schmierseife rein und riecht einfach
schön sauber nach seife und da genau
nehmen wir noch öl dazu und da braucht
jetzt auch kein teures besonderes öl
sondern ich habe einfach ganz gerne nach
dem putzen dass es eben auch sauber
recht sauber heißt für mich meist
orangen oder zitronen riecht gut gehe
und das sind hier diese bank erhoben
die heißen verbarg aromen von deco back
sind aber im prinzip einfach nur back
öle also die werden wirklich zu 100
prozent aus orangenschale oder
zitronenschale hergestellt und davon
darf so was rein machen die kann man zum
packen und zum putzen benutzen
das reicht schon das reicht jetzt ruhig
mal nicht gut ja und damit pflegen wir
jetzt noch den boden und das machen wir
dann so jeden zweiten tag etwa und dann
ist der boden nicht nur sauber sondern
eben auch schön gepflegt
machen wir das zusammen mit ja
[Musik]
also als parkettboden reiniger
schmierseife nehmen dann etwas leinöl
wieder ein paar tropfen orangenöl für
den duft
damit kann ich damit hier den holzboden
vision kann die treppe schöne pflegen
und dann ist vorreiter feiern sie heute
rechts
[Musik]
geschafft habe ich den frühjahrsputz
erledigt zumindest alles bis auf küche
und bad
das mache ich morgen und vielleicht noch
als kurze tipps sind die kinder auch
wieder da als kurze tipps mir hilft
immer extrem wenn ich meine putzen musik
höre
heute war es meine begleitung war auch
angenehm aber mit musik lässt sich
einfacher putzen denn es macht einfach
doppelt so viel spaß weil man mitsingen
und mittanzen kann das ist das eine das
andere ist macht auch genügend pausen
esst und trinkt auch und vergesst es
wirklich nicht dent putzen ist wirklich
anstrengend vor allem wenn man das ganze
haus die ganze wohnung macht unseren
grund putz macht das dürfte nicht
vergessen und dann könnt ihr euch
wirklich alles schön auch aufteilen wie
gesagt heute habe ich den einen teil
gemacht morgen mache ich den rest weil
es wirklich extrem fehle es bei uns und
dann viel spaß beim hissen beim
saubermachen mich befreit sie jedenfalls
sehr ich leg mich jetzt gleich erstmal
in die badewanne oder unter der dusche
und dann schaue ich mir machst schönes
ereignis an also ich hoffe euch hat das
video spaß gemacht wenn ihr öfter sehen
wollt wie ich putze dann schreibt gerne
in die kommentare
und dann bleibt sauber bis zum nächsten
mal tschüss
ach ja ich mache kurze pause für das
minuten nur fünf minuten geschockt bist
du die kameras abgebaut hat und bis die
treppe getrocknet ist dann kann ich die
tücher zum waschen hoch bringen
ja fünf minuten okay